the United States government has pressed
France Germany are the European nations
from which many captured Isis fighters
came to take them back but they did not
want them and refused the United States
will not hold them for what could be
many years and great cost to the United
States taxpayer turkey will now be
responsible for all Isis fighters in the
area captured over the past two years in
the wake of the defeat of the
territorial Caliphate by the United
States America's role in Syria it's
difficult to explain they came to fight
Isis Isis has been all but destroyed in
Syria but America's staying the fight
Isis you see what I mean by difficult to
explain and people are getting impatient
sick of things staying in limbo heck
turkeys done waiting it's going to
invade we have made our preparations
completed our operation plans and given
the necessary instructions we will
conduct this operation on the ground and
in the air tanks and troops are flooding
toward the turkey-syria border we're
talking here about a theater wide
offensive a front line of almost 500
kilometers turkeys serious it wants
America's pet army the SDF which it
views as terrorists gone yes the F Kurds
predominantly aren't going down without
a fight the STF is committed to the
security mechanism framework and has
been taking necessary steps to preserve
stability in the region however we will
not hesitate to turn any unprovoked
attack by turkey into an all-out war on
the entire border to defend ourselves
and our people editor one's been pushing
the idea of the Syria safe zone for ages
he's got millions of Syrian Arab
refugees he wants to resettle them and
there appeared to be progress joined us
and Turkish patrols through this planned
safe zone until Turkey realized what was
going on
limbo America dragging its feet and
stretching the time at
land patrols air patrols we're seeing
all of these are fiction I'm to think of
it America's role in Syria it's like a
doorstop wedged with the door halfway
open sir you can't close it and you
can't open it
and the doorstop does nothing but annoy
anyone trying to get in or out we'll get
something done and it has no good reason
to be there
I mean seriously in a recent
congressional report they argued that
the US should stay in Syria because get
this all those defeated Isis fighters
could potentially theoretically staged
multiple prison breaks and become a
threat the Isis detainee population is a
few prison breaks away from refilling
its ranks for the next phase of battle
talk about running out of excuses I mean
that's like saying that you should
change your car tires because you could
burst the tire in the future who came up
with that was that the intern regardless
the problem with Turkey invading other
than the fact that it's an invasion is
that there are an awful lot of US troops
packed together with the guys turkey
calls terrorists and they're still there
despite rule of Trump's humbug about
leaving we've beaten them and we've
beaten them badly we've taken back the
land and now it's time for our troops to
come back home so we'll be coming out of
Syria like very soon let the other
people take care of it now we are
pulling back in Syria we're going to be
removing our troops so here are trump's
options get out of the way of a Turkish
invasion by withdrawing troops or stay
and risk being bombed by doea NATO ally
if he leaves the liberal mob are going
to go nuts and shout all the louder if
he stays well he might have to explain
why American troops are being shot at by
NATO allies it's a tough choice huh
whoever knew the life of a doorstop
could be so complicated
you